I'm sure you'd probably love it if I
came over to your house and we hung out
together that's an interesting idea
repulses me so much let's talk now do
you think it is correct for you and I to
go for a walk wearing facemasks and
being six feet apart
yes see I think I think it's probably
fine again
don't listen to me I'm a clown but
psychologically it's tricky to be honest
you always insisted on social distancing
with me long before but that was only
because of the breath I mean I I don't
think I'm speaking at a school here coz
there anyone who's been to Conan has the
breath of a cooler you could turn
leopard skin back to rabbit you're not
have you're honest I'll give you that
you're an honest man
I think I'm delightful in a kind of
pushy small dose way yeah yeah I love
your background by the way it looks
lovely I've interviewed tons of people
on zoom' this looks gorgeous really does
look like you're at Versailles it's very
nice you know I have made money and I
was left money oh my good
well listen I'm up for a social
distancing appropriate walk whenever you
want to do I'll do that with you at any
time here's the only thing that's good
because the mask will deal with the
breath it's the jokes
remember I've heard them so maybe less
of the jokes from me gets a little media
a little okay I'm gonna I love you Conan
and I can't wait I think we should do
that maybe Sunday I'm learning to
paparazzi I'm here yeah they found me
oh how they hound me I bet they do
Willoughby's is
available now on Netflix I want to get
the words on the bees is this too close
back baby
now the Willoughby's is it's a
fabulously funny and delightful film
with Ricky Gervais Terry Crews fabulous
Terry Crews Maya Rudolph there you go
and I'm leaving someone out that's
fantastic Oh Will Forte Oh
but many people yeah it's a great great
Goods very funny and your vase I believe
it was definitely executive producer
yeah
Willoughby's is is on Netflix I was with
Ricky Gervais in London just just before
this all went down interviewing him for
my podcast I interviewed Jimmy Blake
please welcome the star of the office
Steve Carell oh my god dill jiminy glick
he'd be a perfect interviewer for these
times because she'd probably never bring
up the co vide nineteen he wouldn't know
Mona you wouldn't even know more until
that's what he'd ask so he's sitting
there talking to dr. pouchy and instead
of asking him what do you think is the
appropriate length of time that the
economy should be shut down instead of
asking him that he'd ask is Brad Pitt
spirit or just well that made my day
thank you that's one of my favorite
thank you well listen yes sir
lightful fellow as always you are
fantastic and I love doing your show
more than life it's my favorite show to
do on zoom' it actually is the nicest
thing you've ever said to me I know I'm
sentimental yeah Marv
short you're a great man calling Brian
you're a saint and I'll see you Sunday
all right very good